yo when you do you ever look back at
like I you know I was I was um just
talking with uh my boy Amir about kind
of like the peak Grand Hustle days M
shout out to Dro and and uh obviously
yourself and Bo was in the mix and Iggy
iselia was in the mix Travis everybody
Travis was in the mix it was just such a
crazy like RP um you know Tokyo it's a
lot of us in there just a crazy movement
I mean before he got you know aired out
I mean I love the alpha Mega dude he had
such a crazy voice but do you ever look
back at those days and just like be like
damn like that was like a moment you
know it feels like sometimes we live and
we're a part of history but we don't
know that we're living in it at the time
right and you it probably actually if
you was actually in it you still would
never see it the way that the outside
see like the way the world saw it right
like for instance me right past the
music like when I come around whether it
be the music or just for me being on
front line of helping people people be
amazed to me I'm normal as can be it's
just the normal me so I don't I don't
really
realize what I am to people you know
what I'm saying and even when you speak
of the hustle game on it
was yeah everybody talking about
hustling everybody we Hustle Gang
clothes Hustle everything you know what
I'm saying to
where I think because we were living in
it it's kind of hard to see what
everybody else so but we definitely
appreciate it because [__] you know that
that was at that time that everything
people was doing was the Hustle Gang you
know for sure for sure I think back to
like the was it the Bett Awards when
like drama was DJing and just everybody
it was just a moment for sure man a
moment in that's why I was I was also
talking about it with drama I was like
bro how crazy was that yeah shout out to
them you know they working on a PSC
album right now really pimp squad click
yeah they they back um I just left from
out there me and T just shot the video
to the record SW I'm and I was out there
for his movie premiere make sure
everybody go check out the movie
departments um that's something dope
with a bunch of comedians I going say I
love to see TI like pivot and try to
just do whatever like he's just doing
what he wants at this point like if
you're a legend you can just do what you
want and I don't even think it's that we
do what we want the thing we just
enjoying life that's what I was going to
say like to me he's doing the the comedy
[__] the right way like he's like going
to open mics he's getting on the mic
he's he's he's you know it I feel like
comedy and Hip-Hop there's parallels
like you got to start somewhere you know
what I'm saying and I feel like he's
doing it the right way yeah his that
movie um the movie came out the pist
like what was the movie with a bunch of
comedians back in the day was that car
wash there was a lot of those movies car
saying what what a bunch of big
comedians just I don't know about car
wash I remember the wash with Snoop and
Dr Dre neither y was somebody even way
back then with Richard Pride type yeah I
was born in ' 87
so but yeah so yeah it's it's definitely
one of the ones that's going to count um
a this and that yeah and and it's dope
um even though it's son King in there
too but um I think we at a point life
man we just like that's the reason why I
did this album man we just living like
what's the point of waking up angry
every day or stress or running to the
same walls man we just got to live and
enjoy life like my movie coming out it's
a comedy too oh you got a movie coming
yeah it drop it should drop any day on
Tu it's called Soul um how's the tub
game cuz I've I swear to God my favorite
thing to do is just search up tuby on
Twitter and just watch so you know it's
two part look it's two parts of it right
you do have the bootleg movies but they
great though yeah but some of that [__]
be just funny I can it's hilarious I I I
I was telling him I was like bro we got
the cameras like we should shoot like a
white trash tuby movie it it definitely
would it definitely would go but the
other thing people don't realize [__] to
be be having better movies than Netflix
and other [__] they be having real no
they have like official sh yeah a lot of
official you know what I'm saying yeah
so that's the thing people should
definitely go cuz you know the first
thing they do is like what you did they
go look at Twitter they like man I'm
never downloading Tu like but people who
don't know Tu is free so if you have a
smart TV you're just in the game me and
then you know have Partners like um
murder pain you know Chris and a lot of
them
um I believe T Muller a lot of them you
know they took tuby to another level cuz
we didn't get familiar with tuby till we
start watching the show mgra or 211 or
um uh uh what was the other one love um
I know it's it's a lot of them they got
right now yeah tu's uh Tu special oh
plug love yeah I heard that like they're
really good like like they pay well if
you're yeah you can they I learned about
tuby they say it was a man who shot a
whole video on the iPhone oh I've seen
ran it up bet when I say ran up a bag
ran it
up what are we doing shooting a movie
come on